Good morning John! I really like backstages.
Yesterday... which is today actually
we played - or are about to play, depending on how you look at it - at the... McGlohan Theatre, possibly.
It's in Charlotte, North Carolina. It's a beautiful theater. It has a dome, it has, like, red carpet everywhere,
there's stained glass windows... but upon arriving at a venue the thing I want to see first is the backstage.
I want to see how weird and different it is and I want to try to understand how it works a little bit
even though like when you actually get to a backstage you realize the glamour isn't...
isn't really there. Like, you think about backstage as like a place where only a few people get to go.
There's backstage passes, and that has a very specific connotation
but like it's usually dingy and gross and like there's, you know, like utility sinks.
But every venue is kind of the same from the front.
Like, of course it's very different going from like a beautiful room like this
to like a middle school auditorium
But it's just a stage with a bunch of chairs when it comes down to it.
But the layout of the backstage is always completely different.
Like at the McGlohon we walked down three flights of stairs before we got like to the green room.
And like backstage at
VidCon I mean it looks - and smells -
like a high school cafeteria.
There's sort of two reactions you can have to a backstage.
You can get back there and be like oh, this is, you know, the glamour is gone
I now understand that this is just a room, and indeed kind of a less good room
than all the front-facing parts of a venue.
But then there's the other way to look at it, which is the kind of all the things that make the world actually work
tend to be hidden from us.
They're above the drop ceiling, they're behind the scenes, under the hood.
All the pipes and wires and servers and ducts, we have this instinct to hide them
so that we can like create a nice shiny glossy beautiful thing
that may - it's like all the things that we actually, there's a lot that goes into
are hidden so that we can make it look like magic.
Being able to see and start to understand the magic, I think that's a big reason why I love backstages.
Because they don't have drop ceilings. They're like hey, just we're not gonna pay to make this all fancy.
I'm obsessed with this stuff like if you watch my old tour vlog, from last year,
Oh man, I got myself into some places. I've tried to get myself into some places here... and I failed, unfortunately.
Where's room 2-0-4?
Oh no... Hank's gotta go in there!
It's locked. No!
Nothing - just the secret room is locked.
Oh, look at the weird dirt! Oh, that would have been cool.
The other dressing room also has a secret door with a less creepy way to get to it
But is it also locked? Probably.
Probably... oh, I love little doors!
Ahhhhhh
Any door that is not the size of a full-height man is like the fit... like, I don't know what it is...
It gets me very... intrigued.
I think sometimes we're too good at hiding the hard work that goes into making things function.
But like I love beautiful design, I love beautiful things
but I also want that magic to be stripped away a little bit so that we can appreciate
the beauty of the function. Like, a car engine is as beautiful as a car
and CPU is as beautiful as a phone, and a backstage is as beautiful as a stage.
John, I'll see you... uh, when I see you.
John, it's been really fun to hang out. The tour bus is amazing! Though I have identified a problem with it.
Yeah... I don't know how this has happened, but they are.... they're... they're just everywhere.